what a pleasure so nice to meet you I
I'm yes nice to meet you as well
introduce yourself uh my name is Jeff
Beck I um have been a computational
neuroscientist for the last 15 years or
so um we
study well we do a lot of things um
we're interested in the basian brain
hypothesis we study how um uh humans and
animal behaviors can be modeled as
basian inference this so there's a lot
of like animal and human behavioral
modeling involved but um we're also
critically interested in um how the
brain can actually implement the
operations of probabilistic reasoning
how the brain encodes information as
information quite literally um but in
particular how it encodes um probability
distributions and how neural circuits
can perform the operations of
probabilistic inference fascinating um
maybe we should touch on the the brain
first do you think the brain acts as if
it performing basan inference or it
actually
does yes no so I I I I'm refusing to
answer your question right because
what's the difference between as if and
actually does right so from my
perspective does it matter right whether
the brain whether you're so I'm going to
model you right now okay and I could
model you either 100% accurately
whatever that means or I could model you
as if you were performing Basi and
inference so wh which is
preferred
well I I guess if if you said what's the
difference could you argue that this
basian modeling is sufficiently
fundamental to explain everything we
needed to do so I think that it's
fundamental to empirical inquiry period
right at the end of the day the best
thing you can do is a basian model and I
think you can make a variety of
arguments as to why it's a it's it's a a
normative take on empirical inquiry
period I completely agree with that so
basian analysis is beautiful it's the
it's one of the most principled things
which exists I think of it actually as a
continuation of um you know uh logical
reasoning but in the domain of
uncertainty yeah well in in any
empirical domain where you are relying
on uncertain information relying on
sense information where you are um
trying to make statements about
something that you do not directly
observe right yes yes so reasoning about
uncertainty and and what is unobserved
okay this is really interesting I mean
um maybe this this isn't aside but the
only potential issue I see with basian
analysis is the dependence on some kind
of structure which represents your
domain and it feels to me like there are
an infinite number of possible
structures that could have predictive
power so there seems to be a kind of
chick in an egg situation of how do we
know we've got the right structure and
what veilance does the structure have
for me the structure has to be
intelligible by other humans so there
are presumably some structures that
would work really well that wouldn't
make any sense to us
MH so how do we find the right structure
right well
so what what would be ideal right so the
ideal situation okay so all knowledge is
conditional right I think we can sort of
say that right and it's conditioned on
two things right it's conditioned on the
data that you have acquired what you
call your list of facts right and and
the models that you have considered so
I'm going to replace your use of the
word structure with model right so I
have a bunch of different models for how
the world can work and I represent them
probabilistic as a generative model
right and then I want to choose the the
best model that I've got right based on
the data that I've observed so my
conclusions are based on those two
things right the data and the set of
models that I have considered right and
so ideally what you would consider all
possible models all possible structures
rely on the automatic aams razor effect
of BAS an inference to tell you which
model is like the most likely model in a
given domain or maybe just in you know
in general we of course do not do that
because it's it requires some sort of
insane exhaustive search we cannot
possibly check the set of all possible
models but that's what we would like to
do but we can't but but it it sort of
doesn't matter right from a practical
perspective we could sort oh well I'll
only consider the models to which I have
like computational access like I can
actually like evaluate in some way MH um
but we can always rely on this sort of
automatic aams razor effect to tell us
which is the best in a fairly normative
way right is that makes sense yeah yeah
it it does absolutely so um as you say
there are many appeals appeals to
Infinity when we talk about machine
learning and basan Analysis there's like
you know um Universal function
approximators and and you can talk about
this infinite selection of of models and
so on but we live in the real world we
we have practical computational and so
we only ever consider a finite number of
models and that's fine there's nothing
wrong with that and you could even
describe science as being composed of of
of fundamentally two steps right data
acquisition and then exploring the space
of models all models are of course wrong
and I like to paraphrase Einstein just a
little instead of saying but some are
useful I like to say some are simply
more wrong than others yes right but
it's still just a model you know I mean
when when I occasionally pretend to be a
philosopher I tend to say things like
you know um you know a proper basian
like places no metaphysical significance
on the parameters in Laten variables of
their models it's just a model yes right
I don't you know an electron is a label
for an equation not something that you
know that's controversal I guess but
like not something that exists it's a
label for an that would be a sort of a
very extreme you know borderline crazy
intake on on on basy and reasoning yes
indeed okay well let let's talk about
where we're at with active inference
then so we already you know we've been
doing machine learning for many years
and that seems quite sclerotic and rigid
because we train a model um we do it
offline and it gives us something which
is akin to if we did maximum likelihood
estimation in in the beijan regime and
then we just go and run it usually we
run it on stationary data we don't run
it in an agent framework usually there's
only one of them and what we're talking
about now is is with this active
inference is we have an agent framework
every single agent has a model and we're
actually acting in our environment we're
seeking information we're getting
information back and we're dynamically
building our model and that in some
sense is a kin to this model search
process that you're talking about but
it's it's very efficient it's got some
interesting properties right it has it
has sort of optimal experimental design
built in it it allows the agent to sort
of run around and say hey look what's
the data that would would actually be
the most informative data I should go
get that right and that's to some extent
what we do in the lab right what we we
don't just sort of like you know run
around taking pictures of things and say
what the hell is going on right we
design an experiment to help us separate
different hypotheses we have about how
the world works right let's build that
into Behavior it's it's sorry it's been
remarkably effective in the lab let's
build it into behavior and I think
that's one way of summarizing what
active inference is interesting okay
um I mean empiricism is quite an
interesting thing because it kind of
implies that that you can follow the
data and there are some folks who think
that it's not possible to do that and
and you need to have a prize that tell
you something about the world in order
to do that but um I guess like maybe we
should start with with with that so um
if you're just empirically searching
through the data you know like we humans
have this magical ability to perform
abduction right because you're talking
about these hypotheses we seemingly just
grab them out of thin air and we're
we're searching this exponentially large
space and if I said to you well
cynically if I followed the data
empirically like maybe I wouldn't be
able to find those hypotheses like what
would you say to that I would say it's a
good thing that we've been born with a
rather elaborate set of models right
that have that have been that have been
refined by Evolution and discovered to
be useful over time right we're not
doing so unlike you know sort of you
know like a machine learning algorithm
right it's not doing Den we don't do
denovo inference yeah we do inference
based on a great deal millions and
millions of years of information that
we've Incorporated to inform our priors
and to and to give us a good starting
point to allow us to do inference
quickly and efficiently I'm so on board
with that yeah so I'm I'm a huge fan you
know there's no predictions without
itions um are prior through some process
of magical resonance you know we we've
been endowed through the laws of nature
with these cognitive priors these
primitive priors and um to what extent
do you think they're they're Universal I
mean because I'm I'm a big believer that
in some sense there's no there's no
magical pure intelligence right these
priors tell us something about the
environment that we're in all
intelligence is situated specialized I
mean would you agree with that yeah
absolutely I'm not sure what you mean by
Universal though in this context well so
um go five people I've got many friends
go five friends and they believe in a
pure they've got a kind of comput
computer science approach to
intelligence and they say um the located
in Prior is universal it would exist
even if the universe didn't exist you
know or contains in I put something in a
container I put the container in the
other room the thing is now in the other
room because it's in the container or
there semantics of events for example
they argue that and and I can get on
board with there being let's say natural
prize and cultural social cultural
situated prior don't don't necessarily
have to exclude one to have the other
right right okay so so Universal is sort
of things that necessarily follow which
is it's sort of like saying like well if
I were to sort of think about all of the
models that I could build right all of
them have there are certain kinds of
relationships that necessarily must
exist that's the idea yes I mean I think
that's true I'm not sure how I would
formalize that or necessarily make use
of that but it certainly is the case
that like some models you would you
know you certainly want to avoid models
that contain inherent contradictions or
make inference really hard and so that
sort of like gives you some constraints
on the set of models that you'd like to
consider um I don't know about like like
when I build a model what do I do I
start drawing circles and I say this
this latent variable talks to this one
in some way and it talks to this one in
some way and that imposes my structure
it's like the graph is is the structure
yeah and I can sort of put them together
arbit completely arbitrarily and so I
don't see how there's like you know like
fast and strict rules other than like
there are you know the all the
relationships are probabilistic and so
you're talking about some sort of high
you know sort of high level semantic
logical operations that are that that
are that necessarily true yeah and that
makes a lot of sense to me but that's
not actually how we how I at least tend
to tend to do things when I construct a
model right these loose probabilistic
relationships that we that have some
kind of structure like a tree structure
or a line structure or Circle structure
and um um but they don't often map sort
of they map neatly onto causal thinking
but not necessarily neatly onto logical
thinking right yeah well I mean there's
an interesting interplay between the two
ideas I mean go GOI folks and
rationalists that they're I think quite
similar but they they think that
knowledge is a binary um so they you
know they only exist in in in the domain
of certainty and we're much more
flexible than that you know we we can we
can probably explains why out for a
second there because I can't think in a
binary way right you have probability
distributions over absolutely everything
there is very little outside of
mathematical knowledge that you have any
certain like like llao said it quite
nicely and I'm going to butcher the
quote of course but like you know all
knowledge is probabilistic right and he
meant all knowledge about the empirical
world right about the universe in which
we live all conclusions are conditional
they are conditioned in my like you know
as I said before they're conditioned on
two things and and they are
probabilistic right they're conditioned
on your models they're conditioned on
your data and all conclusions come with
error bars so so what what you're saying
makes sense to me and and I agree that
in the domain of limited information and
uncertainty then then absolutely but
would would you concede that there are
any situations where you do have
complete knowledge about something so
it's a binary I mean
well okay so what's a fact right this is
this is one that I like I like to poke
my students with like what you know
what's what's the defining
characteristic of a fact or if you're
like you know probability theorist an
event right those are the things that
you can say occurred with probability
one yeah right and if you're a basian
it's the stuff you put on the left side
of you like P of data given model right
yeah um you
know you I can see somebody sort of
saying oh well there are certain things
that are that are facts right like but I
I have very difficulty seeing which
things are always are facts like you can
tell me this happened but then but I
still have to do an I still have to
solve a probabilistic reasoning problem
like are you honest did it actually
happen are you delusional you know I can
you know sort of like come up with all
sorts of other explanations as to why
you might assert something to be true
which have you know which don't
necessarily involve it actually being
true right so so so what's so so maybe
my model has a binary variable in it
which is it's true or false right but my
conclusions never do yeah that's
interesting I mean I mean we don't we
don't need to talk about go five people
for much longer but um I think in the'
70s they were trying to solve a simpler
version of the problem and a lot of this
comes from reasoning I mean they say
language models don't reason and by
reason they mean kind of like filling in
the semantics so there might be missing
data and with these cognitive priors I
can kind of like fill in the missing um
data by doing some reasoning over the
top now it's not to say you can't do
that with a probabilistic model but but
now now you're kind of sampling and I
guess the complexity comes in when there
are many possible models right and there
are many possible ways of filling in
these semantics and doing this reasoning
and that's where in my mind I'm not
saying it's a problem but that's where
like it gets a little bit um blurry for
me be so but what but so it is blurry
it's and it's blurry by Design because
blurry is best is how I would respond to
that and it's sort of like you know I
understand that um I mean I certainly it
would be very nice and it would be very
sort of psychologically compelling and
pleasant if we could say this is the
model right and this is how the world
works works but that's not but I would
say that that's not an empirically
accessible conclusion right it's always
go there will always be uncertainty and
we should just be okay with that right
we should just be like well you know and
at the end of the day what's science
really about is it about discovering
truth no science is about prediction and
data compression and nothing else yeah
right we don't evaluate the quality of
our model based on how true it is
because we can't we can only evaluate
the quality based and its ability to
predict out of sample data MH mhm okay I
mean I'm fascinated by this idea of um
well Maxwell spoke about a an integrated
approach of internalist and externalist
cognition so you have agents that model
themselves that model other agents and
also you can kind of think of um
abstract boundaries that incorporate
many agents and agents will have
different behavioral complexi some will
mimic each other so you know they got
this whole ecosystem of of of agents and
they are modeling something which may or
may not I think it probably does bear
some resemblance to ontological reality
because there's some kind of consensus
mechanism between them but but it
doesn't have to be it can be a almost an
entire hallucination but it's just it's
a really interesting way to think about
building a model by kind of Distributing
into an ecosystem of agents that that
sense make with each other I mean like
what how do you think about all of that
so so one of the one of the things that
I find very appealing about like the
free energy principle and the Markov
blanket story is that it's it is it's
sort of um it's very much fundamental to
how it is
that systems work right so so so
something that hasn't been I think
emphasized enough in the literature is
is the relationship between like systems
identification Theory and like Mark out
blanket so how do you make a nice like
compelling like relatively simple model
of like the universe well you start
drawing circles around things and you
give them labels right um and you sort
of say oh no no no this is a subsystem
this subsystem behaves in this certain
way and this is great because now I can
summarize all these complex interactions
with some you know relatively simple set
of equations yeah right and then I can
just do that over and over again and
have like rules right it is it's taking
this this this this this complicated set
this High massively High dimensional set
of observations and reducing it down to
a few simple mac I mean this is like
statistical physics right we're going to
reduce it down to a few simple
macroscopic variables uh the Markov
blanket story is saying well actually we
really want to reduce it down not to a
few simple macroscopic variabl Ables
like temperature and all that stuff we
want to describe subsystems we want to
segregate our environment into entities
objects right subsystems that then we
can describe and that's exactly what
it's for right is it's for taking this
very very complicated system and
dividing it into something that is
simpler we can call those things agents
we can call them objects the beauty of
the marov blanket thing is that it gives
us a definition of an object type based
on the statistics of its boundary which
is the probabilistic equivalent of
systems identification Theory you don't
care what going on inside two objects
that have the same boundary interact
with the universe in the or the their
environment rather in the same way and
are therefore same object type right so
this is it it really is sort of you know
it's it's just a very useful way to
solve a dimensionality reduction problem
that's really really really complicated
yeah yeah okay so so active inference is
the process of you know creating such a
model or allowing a model to emerge well
well I would I would say SE so there
there so active inference is sort of how
we if
um one way to think about active
inference is is that it's the in if if
you start dividing the world into these
subsystems and subsystems that that that
exist for any amount of time must have
achieved some sort of homeostatic
equilibrium with their environment right
and then you can sort of say well okay
how did they do that like what's and
it's s active inference sort of
necessarily follows from that if you
have achieved a homeostatic relation R
you are doing some kind of you are you
know you doing some sort of PR
prediction about your environment and
reacting to it in a way that allows you
to maintain your identity okay right and
here your identity is the statistics of
your boundary the statistics of your
Markov blanket is what determines your
identity yeah right and everything any
any object can be characterized this way
even stupid objects right even I mean
rocks are doing terrible inference about
their environment but you can still
model them using the exact same set of
equations because as an object it has a
blanket okay okay a couple of thoughts
on that so um I'm trying to link it to
just cognitive science in in general so
we we have these abstract categories and
and we have you know words and semantics
they point to those categories we
communicate in words and you could argue
whether language is a system of of
thought or communication but it it
doesn't matter we we we've come up with
this representational system to
communicate with each other and in a
sense I guess what I'm getting at here
is um we're implementing a kind of
mediation pattern right so the the the
categories the words the things that we
use to communicate with each other they
mean something to us there's an
intelligibility component to it because
yeah we both agree that we need to have
a map to represent the territory we need
to like you know simplify the map not
only for our own existence and planning
but also like communication and and um
social complexification so it feels like
there are some guardrails on on the type
of models we build not necessarily about
representational ability but about
social
complexification so what do you mean by
guard rails right well I guess like in
order for me to mediate with you so for
you to understand my model and what I'm
talking about it feels like there's a
trade-off between representational
Fidelity and communication um ability
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to answer the question I think
you're asking and hope it's the question
that you are asking so so communication
you
know so I would like to communicate
maybe say my model to you so I have this
model in my head for how the world works
I'd like to communicate it to you this
is actually a really difficult problem
just in general like you know and we use
language to do this that's what language
is ostensibly for yeah right but how do
we do that right because the model that
I have is internal to me I have some
abstract State space and there's
absolutely no way you could know what my
abstract State space is because it's in
my head right it is not in yours and I'm
trying to communicate something like
like that you know that that contains a
representation that to which you have no
access okay so what do I do do well what
I do is I try to communicate to you in a
way that makes my model grounded right
and so one way to do that is is that is
consistent with this sort of prediction
and data compression view of science is
to make sure that that all I don't
communicate to you hey like right now
we're in state number seven and then you
go oh you know I think we're in state
number nine so seven and nine must be
okay we could do sort of do it that way
but another way to do it is all I ever
communicate to you is effectively
predictions yeah predictions live in the
domain of observation space right
they're they're the grounded form that
that's the grounded thing that comes out
of your models is I can tell well you
know the cat's about to walk into the
room and things like that and then you
you know if I communicate to you solely
in terms of predictions right then I
don't need to know what your internal
model is I don't need to understand the
structure of your internal model I am
now speaking in the language that you
necessarily understand now I should this
is this is the caveat that I should have
started with I am by no means an expert
in like language and Linguistics and and
how they this is this is just me
randomly now thinking about like well
you know how would you make
communication work between two agents
that have like two complete you know
that almost surely have two completely
different models for how the world works
oh UND undou and the only thing that I
can think is to make it grounded is for
them to speak in the language of
prediction right I think you are going
to do X and I think this is about to
happen to you but but on on that though
um yes I completely agree so I mean it
reminds me of um sort of Jeff Hawkins
view of you know we we've got the Matrix
in our in our head we condition each
other and so on but um you know our
phenomenology could be very very
Divergent you know we we're just
mediating through prediction but the
thing is I think it's a bit um almost
magical to say oh we're mediating
through prediction what is a prediction
the the um the domain of that prediction
is is the the environment that that
we're in right so that's right yeah and
so so in a sense there is there is an
environmental dependency on that
mediation process right yeah because it
because yeah I mean you know if you
think about this in terms of like agents
and blankets right one of the you know
when we when we model things in that
framework it's always the case that that
a blanket is or an agent is embedded in
an environment and two agents cannot
share a bl by definition of what a
blanket is like two blank blankets
cannot be shared right if blankets start
to overlap what do they become they
become one thing not two things right
and so all interactions are mediated by
the environment within this sort of
modeling framework right and so
Communications are Med you know I
communicate to you like my voice goes
out but it actually goes through the
environment and makes it to your ears
right and it's the same way right is
that so our Communications are mediated
by the environment so odds are we are in
some sense speaking in the language of
the environment yes yes exactly exactly
okay um again but not an expert here
just no no no some of this is is like
random speculation yeah we we will we
all speculating when when it comes to um
semantics and and Min and and by the way
I mean what what you said really
resonated with me and I'm fascinated
with with the emergence of meaning I
spoke with Daniel dennit recently all
about this and he's got some very you
know interesting ideas about the
intentional stance and stuff like that
but um yeah it's really weird when you
talk about phenomenology and and and
meaning and um you know the hard problem
and the intentional stance um so many
people just think oh it's intellectual
masturbation you're just you're kind of
talking about this philosophy of mind
this this weird way of thinking about
things and I'm always left with the
question of well how what what is the
cash value like I I think it's a really
good reference frame for us to
understand and Comm communicate these
ideas but as Kyle said yesterday well
there's no real phenomenology it's just
their it's just their world model it's
it's their it's it's just a world model
that includes other things that are
probably somewhat like me like you know
one way to think about philosophy of
mind right that sort of abstracts away
the whole philosophy part is I need a
philosophy of mind because I need to be
able to predict your behavior yes you
know it's that simple it's that
pragmatic yes you know it might be nice
to have a coherent philosophy of mind
that told us something like really
profound but if you're a harsh
instrumentalist and I tend to sort of go
in that direction when behaving as a
scientist but you don't yes all you need
is the ability to predict someone else's
Behavior having a theory of
mind is really helpful to that end so
that so a theory of mind is also about
prediction and data compression and
nothing else and just before we leave
theory of Mind are you a um are you a
materialist are you you know do do you
believe that c i mean we're talking
about certain organizations of material
here in in a certain pattern which which
potentially gives rise to let's not call
it um you know conscious self-awareness
but something which is as if it is a
mental state so so you're kind of No
Nonsense in that respect right well it
depends on like like the day of the week
and what pair of pants I'm currently
wearing right it's sort of like you know
when functioning as a
scientist that's sort of foundational I
think that's implicit in the entire
approach right is that there is this you
know but when I'm wearing my like
Buddhist Quaker pants right it's like
you know I obviously have a very
different View and I don't you know it's
you know so I I often don't know how to
answer that question like I don't know
completely because on the one hand you
know when I'm functioning as a scientist
right you know harsh
instrumentalist that's you know that is
the approach I have committed to taking
yeah right but when I'm sitting around
like thinking about how you know how
things really work and like you know
what I care about and things like this I
believe like crazy things like oh there
is a moral Center to the universe right
you know there are like nonarbitrary
Notions of right and wrong right and so
but you know I don't bring those to work
right you know and you know and I do
have a lot of like sympathy for shoing
or view right it it's all mind yeah and
and and you know you could talk to like
I don't know I came across the term neom
materialism the other day and I my first
thought was what's the difference
between neom materialism and Neo
idealism because if I were to put Neo in
front of either of those words it would
end up meaning the same thing yes right
and so is it all mind does mind arise
from matter I think those are both real
possibilities yeah and I but I'm more
inclined like like my my intuition is
more on the sort of idealist view like
it it's all mind oh interesting um but
objective
idealism yeah yeah so you still you
still think there there that's some kind
of I mean that's that's where I lean but
that's not where I work yeah and I mean
speaking for myself as well I mean I I
guess I I compartmentalize I mean we're
we're a science podcast and in the
scient mean there was that that letter
recently about IIT and and pan psychism
and many philosophers um talk about
philosophy of mind they they say it's a
reductio ad absurdum which implies pan
psychism therefore we must throw it out
and I'm thinking I don't have a huge
problem with Pan psychism um it's not
massively dissimilar to people who think
that you know certain configurations of
material give rise to to mental States
like that's that's just as spooky as as
saying all material has mental States
because it's a property of the universe
does you know for people just to say
know there's a bright line and that's
pseudo science and that's not pseudo
science that seems a bit ridiculous to
me well I mean I I have I have some
sympathy because you use the word
science right to say that you know this
is why like when I like when I come to
work and function as a scientist I put
on my materialist pants right and well
but but could I touch on that because I
I I think that there might there might
be a little bit of
empiricism bias that I'm hearing the
only reason I I say that is because you
said it's all about you know compressing
representing the data but I mean chsky
would say language models the reason
they're not a theory of linguistics is
like you know they a scientific theories
should say why are things this way why
are things not this way and I get even
like you were saying with morality you
know it's notum said you can't get an A
from an is you know so he's saying
empiricism doesn't work for some things
there are some things where we've got
this magical process and we say no the
thing things are this way and the data I
got that from the data yes I like to say
that the Rookie eror of moral philosophy
is confusing is and ought and so when
when I'm at work it's it's it's I'm
living in the is world like what is like
how do things work what you know how do
I make good predictions about the future
and things yes and it's like orthogonal
to how the how the world should be right
absolutely but that's fascinating well
um we should talk about you know you're
doing some really interesting work with
optimization now the the biggest problem
I would say not problem but challenge
with this um basian approach to uh
Building multi-agent Systems is that we
have a kind of computational complexity
that grows exponentially with the
cardinality of the representation the
representation is a discret
representation which is really cool oh
no it's not it's not I was going to like
contrast it to Jeff Hawkins HTM you know
because it he was an example of a guy
doing very exciting stuff many many
years ago which wasn't neural networks
now they've gone back to neural network
but tell me what what are you working on
okay so so
um there I I I I'm my my belief is is
that is that the the project of most
interest is you know tractable Basi and
inference yes for large models scaling
things up and um one of the one of the
tricks that we're doing is is we want to
do like gradient free learning and so
it's so it's sort of very different than
you know how your large language models
are fit right you calculate your grade
and you take a little step one of the
nice things about about um being basan
or Bas you know basan reing is that um
it enables you to construct certain
classes of somewhat limited models right
for which you can do inference and
learning very in in very big steps and
parameter space and so there you're
you're not I mean you being a little
loose with language here but you're not
like Computing gradients and taking
little steps and following to their
Optimum you know instead what you're
doing is you're looking in a particular
direction in parameter space and because
you've constructed your model in a
certain way you can just sort of say oh
if I look to the North or the South I
can see that oh the the actual minimum
of my objective function along that line
is right there and I teleport to it and
then I look east and west and do the
same thing over and over again that's
what I mean by gradient free learning
we're not just following the path to a
minimum we're taking these massive steps
in parameter space now this has been
known for a very long time but this
approach was kind of abandoned because
the belief was right that that that you
could really only do this for a very
limited set
of generative models and it's true right
as soon as you say I would like to do
this sort of like coordinate descent
learning or however you want to put and
take these massive steps you're
basically constraining yourself right
you're saying that that the allowable
set of models is really is really really
limited so it's kind of like abandoned
it sort of like pushed to the side
because what we really want is if we
want like a probabilistic programming
language like pyro which is like which I
do love by the way I think pyro is great
why because any you can specify any
generative model mhm right and you know
your approximate and then like make some
statements about your guide or your
approximate inference algorithm just
press go and it does gradient descent
and it finds the solution it's
incredibly powerful it's not super fast
but it's incredibly
powerful
um but you can get a great speed up and
Improvement if you don't make something
so General and so that's the approach
that that we've been taking it was as I
said it was abandoned because it was it
is a limiting approach you cannot just
specify any old generative model an
arbitrary generative model cannot be
specified ifed in this framework in in
such a way that it allows you to do this
kind this this sort of fast big step
gradient free learning but it turns out
and this is the reason why I got really
excited um you know recently was is that
well you know they're actually the class
of models that you can use are actually
pretty darn powerful in fact the
attention module that
makes that that that you know you could
argue really made large language work
the Transformer
it turns out the Transformer is in this
class of models and what class is is
that it's
so the best way to put it would be so I
mean what's a Transformer Transformer is
ultimately a mixture of experts
model oh it's so interesting because
there are I think there are 20 different
descriptions and that that's that's one
of them that's my favorite one and the
reason it's my f and you can and if you
just sort of if you write down a mixture
of experts model a certain kind of
mixture of experts model and then say
okay well what's the inference algorithm
right so it's a general of model so
there's like some lat that you'd like to
infer you say well what's the inference
algorithm for it and then you can say oh
look well first I have to do this
calculation and then I have to do this
calculation I do you can map those
exactly onto what like literally exactly
the structure of the equations is
identical to what a Transformer does you
know there's a few exceptions like oh
well you there's no like added Norm step
right but like it's just a normalization
it's not doing you know this this is how
I rationalize these things yeah um so if
that's the case right if you can if if
if what is currently believed to be the
most powerful
component right of large language models
the thing that really made it work right
so this is the self- attentional
Transformer is implemental is Implement
you know if you can learn the parameters
of that yeah in a gradient free way in
this perfectly Bas in a basian way with
gradient free learning then then at
least in principle right you have you
can you should be able to do anything
that like a large language model could
do and you might even be able to learn
it faster like if you if you look at
learning rates on your like you know
gradient descent right how does it start
out so here's my loss function right so
this is bad loss this would be good and
eventually you're going to get over here
and you start learning you're doing
gradient descent and your loss function
is like not doing squat right it's not
changing not changing not changing not
changing and at some point like like you
know the algorithm starts to learn
something right and your loss goes you
know your loss goes down and down and
down and down and then there's this you
know in fact there's often a very rapid
decrease and then a long period of
refinement right the be the beauty of
the beuty of doing gradient free
learnings you get to skip that initial
phase where you're where where the model
does is is doing terribly terribly
terribly terribly you can like get rid
of all of that in like just a few
iterations of of of these sort of
coordinate descent steps right you can
get to a pretty deep not not not not NE
not awesome not like perfect but you can
get really good really fast learning out
of it when you take this approach so
there's quite a few things I want to
pick up on there and um first of all so
one of the I mean maybe we should just
talk about some of the assumptions so
yeah that there there's you have to make
assumptions all over the place and the
reason why gradient descent is so um
ubiquitous is because it it always works
well it always works and and weirdly
because you know we always had the curse
of dimensionality but like weirdly um in
stochastic gradient say more dimensions
are better there are more paths to a
basin we find the Basin very quickly
like if anything my experience doesn't
completely jive with yours like when I
when I look at training runs you always
get this characteristic exponential you
know kind of decline on on on the loss
function and then and then this but you
don't see two phases or you don't see
like you know a struggle phase followed
by a rapid learning phase followed by a
struggle phase followed by another
learning phase right we tend to see that
because of because you get like you know
because you do have these sort of Saddle
nodes in your in your in your loss
function right where you can sort of
like you know you get to something it's
not actually a minimum but the gradients
slow down and they speed up I I guess I
I have seen it but I guess the weird
thing is when I've looked at training
runs especially the the larger the model
it's almost like um you know like
there's a LW of averages thing going on
where it just converges on this kind of
power law distribution and it always
looks the same and but yeah but but that
that's that's the thing so it's about um
like how we encode representations in a
vector space so like we we make this
essentially they're all curves there's a
surface to it and we're traversing this
surface and now we're saying okay well
we we want to work in in a domain which
is potentially discret so we have
discontinuities and it's a completely
different representation of the target
problem we want to De gradient free
optimization and I I guess you're kind
of saying the tradeoff is that we we're
making certain assumptions now in this
domain that we yeah we're using a
limited set of models and that that that
that that that's the ultimate trade-off
the ultimate trade-off is is that you
can do gradient descent with any loss
function right and autograd is you know
I mean you can blame autograd for
everything autograd is like why we do it
it works so well right I I I you know
when I was a kid back in my day you know
we had to compute those gradients
ourselves and so now of course you know
we have some this amazing tool that does
it for us and that's one of the reasons
why it's become so popular like the
coding has become so easy and it really
is truly amazing right um that's the
beauty of that approach the beauty of
that approach is gradient descent
learning is accessible for any loss
function whereas this kind of learning
is not accessible for any loss function
right you have to it's really only
accessible for a certain class and that
that again was why I I suspect this is
why it was dropped right because you're
placing limitations on the class of
models that you can consider but if that
class is powerful enough right if it
includes
Transformers right if it works not just
in discrete domains but with continuous
variables and does the and and makes it
easy to mix the two which is actually
like what really makes it work is the
mixing of discret and continuous yeah um
then maybe this isn't that big of a deal
maybe we should be doing this instead
right maybe this is a route forward for
fast learning for fast online learning
for something that really resembles one
shot learning not where you've like
actually snuck the task and in the back
end in the data that you trained on but
you know you're able to sort of say no
no no no I have this brand new data and
it just takes a couple iterations of my
algorithm to get me to a reason not the
best solution but to a reasonably good
like idea of how I should proceed okay
okay so so I mean so with with this um
gradient free optimization approach that
you're working on I understand it might
be domain specific there might be
different flavors depending on on on the
approach but I mean if we if we just
take a representative example um what's
the time complexity like how how does it
relate to the cardinality of the data
the you know the way that the data
domain is represented Etc I mean that
question is very model specific so I
guess I could I could answer it by
giving an example is that is that all
right yeah okay so
um in a dynamic setting it's no more
it's no more laborious than running like
a simple forward backward algorithm over
time right it's no more laborious than
like a common filter right it's it's on
par with that right I mean you know
there's a few extra calculations that go
in there but the complexity is on you
know if you're just it it's not more
sophisticated than that I think that's
probably the the shortest answer that I
can give without like feeling I need to
dive for a pen and paper yeah
interesting and and we are in in a kind
of continual learning setting now as
well because I I think just from a
mindset point of view a lot of folks are
still in this in this mindset of you
know offline batch training no agent and
this is
aely but you're obing this the dams of
this over time um how are you how are
you measuring it what does good look
like what does uh what does good look
like yeah so let's say you've got a
multi-agent system and and you're I mean
presumably you would even represent the
data generation process as an agent in
the system I don't know how yeah which
we do yeah so I can tell you about like
the marov blanket detection algorithm
that we have if you like which is sort
of like um it's not designed for
necessarily predicting what an AG will
do it's a designed for sort of you know
identifying what an agent is and typing
it right so the output of the algorithm
is something like you know there's a in
the in like the fun version of it like
you know there's a cell and the cell is
like going through you know it starts
out as a blob of dots and it evolves and
initially it evolves like something that
looks like a cell membrane this is in
particle lenia if you're familiar with
particle lenia which is really cool
simul if you haven't played with it if
anyone's listening who hasn't played
with it particle lening is a blast right
it's it's a great toy and so what
happens right you start out with a blob
of particles and they kind of form into
a cell membrane and then there's some
stuff in the middle and it's just sort
of like oozing around and then the cell
membrane develops these like uh flagella
I guess you could call them right and
then meanwhile as the fugel are have are
evolving to use the term loosely right
um the the a cell nucleus is evolving to
like the stuff in the middle goes from
being like Blobby to being comp you know
uh
to being like you know a compact thing a
compact little circle with like little
organel that are sort of like you know
zooming around it in some way and so so
what would you like what would you like
to be able to do with like a simulation
like that well what you'd like is you'd
like an algorithm that sort of says
that's the cell membrane right that's
the nucleus and you'd like it to be
based solely on Dynamics and so that's
what we did was we sort of said okay any
given scene right is composed of a bunch
of elements that are all moving around
and they're interacting in some way
we're going to model that that as a
bunch of objects which are which again
in this lexicon is like the same as
agent right because they have you know
each object has an internal Dynamic
right it has a boundary that that that
it interacts with the with with the
environment with and then there are lots
of these things right and so we sort of
we specify that structure and our
macroscopic model of the whole system
right is going to consist of a bunch of
these guys right um and then we just fit
it right so we sort of say it's like
we're going to find like n objects and
the way that we're going to fit is by
looking at the Dynamics right who's
interacting with who so the way I like
to think about this is that it's you can
think about this in terms of like
dimensionality reduction right I have
all these particles in my system and I
would like to Cluster them in a way
right that sort of says oh these guys go
together they're all interacting
strongly and they there's a simple set
of macroscopic variables which all have
their own dynamics that determine how
they interact with their environment and
each other to some extent though
interactions between the objects is
always mediated by the environments yeah
yeah uh so well a few a few thoughts on
that I mean first of all Lena is is
absolutely amazing it we did a show on
emergence and we were talking about
about Conway's Game of Life and Lena is
basically the continuous version of that
yeah and I think there's a couple of
other tweaks as well so most of the time
in celer autom you do synchronous
updates but I think this this has like a
like a stochastic upate it's also just
beautiful it's absolutely it's amazing
it's it's gorgeous to watch right it's
amazing I think there's a channel called
Bert Chan where he's got loads and loads
of um visual visualizations of Lena but
yeah but I'm glad that you gave that
answer though because that was kind of
the direction I wanted to go in so in
the artificial life community that they
build lots of like emergentist um
systems like you're describing and I
always have the question that okay so
I've now essentially grown this system
so this system has taken on very complex
functional Dynamics and um you know like
there we can categorize some of these
phenomena macroscopic phenomena like
gliders yeah and we can build
recognition algorithms and we can like
look at as you say objects that interact
with each other and so on but it kind of
feels like now we're in this space where
you know we were talking about mediation
and intelligibility earlier like you
know we've got no way really of
describing other than like in very
simple terms what's going on in the
system right
so well I'm going to parse that out as
saying like a lot of times when we do
that kind of categorization there's a
lot of like post talk analysis and
rationalization is why we would call
this a thing and that a thing and it's
sort of like yeah that's the beauty of
the approach that we're taking is is
that it's completely agnostic as to what
a thing is it just says that whatever a
thing is its Dynamics can be summarized
as having a Markov of blanket right and
that that's it that that's that's all we
assume and the beauty of the approach
that we're taking is is that you can
have different kinds of objects so what
does the algorithm discover when we
apply it to this like particle lenia
thing well what it discovers is that the
cell membrane is a kind of object that's
like object one I'm just making up
numbers right and then the initial blob
that's kind of nucleus like in the
middle is like object two and it
discovers that and why does it discover
that it discovers that because the
particles that make up those things are
strongly interacting with one another in
in in a way and you know and so we can
treat them as having some low
dimensional dynamical systems
representation and then there's a
blanket and all and then they're sort of
weakly interacting with everything else
and that's all just sort of discovered
you know by the but then the cool thing
is is that as the cell membrane develops
fella
mhm right what ends up happening is that
the algorithm you know says oh that's
not a cell membrane of type one anymore
that's a new thing because it has a new
kind of Dynamics right the Dynamics tell
us like what kind of thing we've got yes
right and you get all this for free
right now some cave asked does it work
perfectly no nothing works perfectly but
it works well enough that we get sort of
reliable results and and my suspicion is
the version two of this algorithm which
which will um have access to more
sophisticated dynamical systems modeling
under the hood yeah right will be a lot
better and we we'll start to be you know
yeah like truly an amazing thing so so
this is fascinating because I've I've
always believed that for an approach
like this to work well you know we're
dealing with essentially complexity and
I think that the way that systems like
you know like artificial life type
systems overcome um uh you know overcome
brittleness is by um using this kind of
self-organization and emergence so you
have to start from the bottom and let it
emerge and I can really see something
like that working obviously with the
caveats that we just spoke about but I
think like some of the other
implementations of active inference are
bootstrapping halfway up so they're kind
of saying okay well rather than like
emerging from the primordial level I'm
going to like take high level abstract
agents and you know I'm I'm going to
start with this kind of like Factor
graph cognitive model and I'm going to
like you know have some bootstrapped
representations from some neuron Network
encoders or something and I'm just going
to like start the thing now and let's
see what happens and it kind of feels
like starting half halfway up the stack
can introduce
brittleness I'm going to have to think
about that um I mean I think one of the
reasons that people do do start halfway
up the stack is because they're trying
to solve the same problem you know
active inference is is is solving the
same problem that like reinforcement
learning is solving and so and so we
sort of you know a lot of cues are taken
from that Community as to like what the
right level of modeling is you know what
kind of pre-processing of my images
should I do and and sort of things like
that it's just sort of the common
approach um and I think that's why it's
now could that be could you know does
that Institute brittleness I don't have
a good answer to that question I don't
really know um but I I you know um what
what I like about active inference in
the setting is you know the way in which
it defines or motivates an agent right
the the fun fundamental difference
between active inference invasi and
reinforcement learning as far as I can
tell um is the definition of an agent
right so how does so how does um
reinforcement learning Define an an
agent consists of three things right it
consists of an inference you know an
inference engine a prediction model
right um and a reward function to
motivate Behavior right so the
prediction model is given the data that
I've already seen what's my prediction
for how world is going to work the
inference engine is how it learns that
right how it learns what that model is
right and then the reward function is
what motivates behavior um reinforcement
learning so one of the one of the
fundamental questions that I think like
Carl has done a really good job of sort
of dealing with or pointing out that
like this is a real issue that we need
to really deeply think about um is where
does the reward function come from so
this is by the way I should the caveat
here is this is my take on active
inference this is not the uniform take
on active inference but so where does
the reward function come from per agent
yeah for any given agent where does it
come from yeah like you know and you
know to to wax philosophical or pretend
to because I don't really know how to do
it for a second it's like there is no
normative solution to the problem of
value function selection right like how
do you decide like that's the right
reward function or that's the right
reward function right how do you how you
know you know and and so the answer that
active inference gives I think is very
sensible the reward function is is is
you know is not the way you want to
motivate Behavior the way you want to
motivate behavior is by saying that an
object has to you know is by is sort
sort of this link back to systems
identification Theory right an object
has to be what it is right and what it
is is defined by its input out its
relationship to the environment so
reward functions in active inference are
replaced by by an expression of
homeostatic equilibrium via the
statistics of the
blanket right and so this is a robust
this I'm actually I am getting back to
your question I swear to
God so this avoids brittleness it but it
but probably not the kind of brittleness
that you were asking about right you
know by saying that the goal of the
organism is to achieve homeostatic
equilibrium as opposed to optimize some
monolithic reward function right you
create a more stable system in my view
right I mean and let's face it reward
function specification is dangerous
right the last thing you want to do is
tell Skynet to end world hunger and have
it decide that the appropriate solution
is kill all humans right whereas if you
told it no no no no here's how the
environment currently is Right we've a
you know we just want to achieve some
kind of equilibrium that looks like this
but is a little different you are
preaching to the choir I mean I Know
Rich suon had this paper out called
reward is enough and I I completely and
utterly disagree reward is a dangerous
it's it's it's it's it's playing with a
loaded gun one 100% and not not only
that I mean it's not too um dissimilar
to you know like a lot of utilitarians
have similar um problems thinking about
you know that rific of of reward but
anyway um no no no this this is really
interesting so so I guess what I was
getting at though is with with lenia um
the agents are actually emergent and
when you see the agents crash into each
other and Linea they they repair
themselves they heal themselves they
kind of like you know they they they
they um develop this GL Global coherence
from some underlying Primitives and then
when we go one step up we now explicitly
model the agents and that's okay because
we've just had a conversation about this
and we think there's something Universal
about the concept of of an agent right
so now now we explicitly model them and
then um we're talking all about okay
well there's this teleology question
with rewards and then we're kind of
thinking well actually a lot of people
say there's something Universal about
the concept of a goal as well but the
individual agents don't have goals goals
are emerging properties of the system so
you know like traditional um GOI people
would actually model one level of
abstraction higher with explicit goals
but we kind of think okay well um
there's also something Universal about
this concept of survival so all they
need to do is focus on resisting those
entropic forces they they they survive
and then the system as a whole will will
you know goals will emerge but I guess
it's just interesting how you can model
all of these different levels of
abstraction and I'm not saying that you
know it would overcome a lot of brist
like you could use active inference you
could build an agent framework to
represent let's say a city or
um like a supermarket or something like
that and and you can swap in the agents
because they have clear interfaces you
can have some agents that specialize in
different things and I can understand
how this could overcome a lot of
brittleness but it's all about making
that kind of tradeoff on that
ladder yes
yeah no I no I no I I I I certainly
agree so I'll I'll uh so one of the
um I always my my my my mind always
starts to wander when I hear the word
emergence because I've never quite
figured out what it means exactly um and
talk about that you know so you know per
perhaps I should ask a question but I
think what the other option here is is
that like so one of the one of the
things about
um so in in lenia right so they specify
this sort of you know so it's learned by
gradient descent they specify an
objective function and the objective sub
function is find something that persists
and it must persist and have a certain
set of properties so for example there
must be like a local motion filter must
must generally go in like a particular
direction that's one way you can build a
lenia agent right I think there there
are many way so I think the Linea that
I'm thinking of is is just a cellular
automaton so so so it's it's basically
Conway game of life it's just very very
simple it's you're just sliding a filter
over so it's overlapping and you're
you're just you know forming a fixed set
of rules that the reason why well no but
no but see the thing is so when they get
those really ripping cool gliders like
and not not in com G I mean sort of the
continuous version of lenia or in
particle lenia you know the way that
they get to those is is they say well
look I don't know what the what kind of
particles might should make up my like I
would like to have an object that does
has this macroscopic Behavior yeah right
and I don't know how to build such an
object so what I'm going to say is that
well the object is made up of a bunch
this isn't particle L the object made a
bunch of particles and those particles
have rules for how they interact and I'm
just going to do gradient descent on the
rules for the interactions of these
different types of particles right so
that I achieve what I achieve a
macroscopic a a Target macroscopic
Behavior I understand what you mean and
so so and this is why I like Linea so
what is it doing it's saying you know
the definition of an object is that it
has a Target macroscopic Behavior which
you could parse out it's not exactly
right but I could you can it's pretty
easy to see how one might map that
notion of what a thing is and how they
get to a thing onto oh what's a Target
macroscopic Behavior or tet you know set
of macroscopic States oh that's like a
home that's a representation of a
homeostatic equilibrium yeah that that
that makes sense so it's all so it's all
kind of one framework I guess is the
direction I was trying to go with this
is that is that the beauty of active
inference you know a lot of a lot of the
utility of active inference you know is
this link to like homeostatic grp that's
how you get cool things to it's one way
to get like agents to form denovo is you
sort of say well no I have a my goal
state is that something has a certain
degree of complexity and some kind of
some class of interactions with his
environment and those persist over time
that is exactly how not exactly is
coarsely how they specified their
objective function for learning in
particle lenia well yes so let's talk
about this so some fascinating things
there so um first of all just just to
clarify that and I love this concept of
steering um an emergent system so it's
it's it's like macroscopic optimization
so yeah you have this target macroscopic
behavior and then we're just going to
like make and then we say what what
parts and pieces do I have to put
together to get there yeah I know and
the reason I don't know whether you saw
this example from Alex M vinf but he he
created a CNN so basically CNN is just a
filter very similar to Lena but um he um
did gradient descent on on the the
weights of the CNN so that when you when
you ran this thing in in a generative
setting it would um produce an entire
lizard or something like that so so
you're um training the network at
microscopic level and then when when you
generate with it it produces This Global
um coherence of a picture of a lizard
and then you can delete parts of the
lizard and it will just grow again right
because it's like you know
self-repairing um but but I think the
key thing is is that the filter is fixed
after you've trained it but anyway the
reason why I think this is interesting
though is when you start steering so so
we we we want to build a a distributed
multi-agent system and we want the
agents to be as autonomous as possible
and when you start having this outer
loop which is kind of steering them with
some fixed objective how is that so
dissimilar to the reward problem that we
had before so yeah that's so a really
good question is is so it you
know so okay what I'll tell a story okay
so here's my story so I um I've got some
you know environment and I'm going to
put a bunch of agents in it and I want
it to be stable so I give an a I view
each agent with a definition of what it
means for it to be in homeostatic
um equilibrium with environment and I
put all these little suckers in there
and then they just go about doing their
thing and and they and because they have
this homeostatic goal right that's what
they achieve right they achieve some
sort of balance and everyone's getting
along and you know maybe maybe they're
like isolating you know some guys are
like oh no no I'm over here and I don't
want to deal with you guys or whatever
but like but basically the system is
stable and there are all these like
agents and they do interact a little
right but maybe only weekly or however
but now what we want to you know and we
can build that we can build that in like
an active emergency setting right
because we just established this
homeostatic goal the agents achieve
homeostasis you know in this sort of go
there's lots of them okay now we have a
different now we have a problem right
we've achieved homeostasis but we
haven't done anything right now what I
want to do is I want to tell my agents
hey
guys like you know can you go get me a
coffee or you know I don't know what to
make up like some stupid task right so
that's new right that wasn't like built
into their like you know definition of
self that wasn't built into their like
you know that's not part of their
equilibrium now I want to guide their
behavior to get them to do something
it's it it is a very interesting
question to how to get these in because
remember these are independent agents
right they've learned to maybe you know
in order to achieve H homeostatic equ
they maybe have learned to like coarsely
communicate with one another in some way
that we could like tease out if we want
to do a hell of a lot of data analysis
or something like that but but that's
all that they can do but that's not what
we want right and so it becomes a very
interesting question is how to get them
to temporarily break from their
homeostatic state to do what you want
yeah right and I I I I can see two
approaches to this but this so we are
now back into speculation
phase I feel it's important to say right
um you know so and and we'd like to do
it with without suddenly saying giving
them a reward function right you're
giving them a goal okay so option one
option one is that we just included the
set of all things we'd ever like them to
do right in as part of their like homeo
definition of self right their
homeostatic so for example like you have
an agent that know that it it its belief
is is that yeah three times a day or
maybe six depending on who I'm working
for so it's my age it's like six times a
day I know I have to go get Jeff a cup
of coffee right and it just it's built
into his equilibrium and he just sort of
does it but of course I'd like to like
bias him towards doing the when I want
him to do it and so we can just clude
you know so so one way to get that to
happen would give us the ability to like
perturb his internal state or poke his
boundary right in a way that that causes
the right reaction to go get coffee
right so I can I can go in and I can
figure out what's the right way to poke
him to disturb his equilibrium to push
him into a state that now how you would
do this that would require like I don't
know right that's going to require like
some some amount of work but it should
be possible right he knows to achieve
homeostatic it goes ibrium so there
should be some way for me to poke him to
get him to engage in one of the
behaviors I have told him is part of his
homeo it's like I want the ball or roll
downhill how do I make that happen I put
it on the hill right and so there's
there's there's got to be a way for us
to like manipulate the agents directly
or poke their boundaries to get them to
engage in a particular task that they
already know to behave it that they've
already learned is one of their tasks
because it was part of their definition
right I get Jeff coffee six times a day
right um and it's just a question figure
how to poke them to get them to like
respond with that particular behavior
when we want it yeah option one but just
on that I think we agree that we we want
to do it in a way which doesn't
introduce brittleness or change thein
right so that's why we that's why we
include it in their definition of self
that's how you avoid Burness right I
tell I I tell this agent that part of
your definition of self is you bring me
coffee six times a day but but but
that's that's the thing so so it's it's
the same thing so it's the same ential
imperative um all of the actions that
the agent does it's using this kind of
balance of energy and entropy all of
that stuff stays the same but I guess
like the the the worry is that by um
creating something which might look like
a fixed behavioral profile could
introduce brittleness but that's not how
we would do it is it we would actually
model it more abstractly in terms of a
kind of Behavioral complexity that needs
to be maintained because you because the
behavior might change over time right we
need to maintain that flexibility right
yeah so I mean that that's the hard
hardest part the hardest part is when
you've taken an agent and you've told it
that this is its job and that that doing
this job every day is how it achieves
like homeostatic equilibrium like it
gets me coffee six times a day and then
I'd like to change the job right now I
want to use this agent to do something
that it's never done before that's the
harder problem right and that's the
problem where well what are your options
well I just I could maybe but you know I
could just go in and change its
definition of self I could just sort of
say oh well instead of like six times a
day maybe the doctor has been talking
had a serious conversation with me and
it's like now I only want coffee three
times a day we could insert that sort of
thing into it definition as well right
we just change its definition of self we
change the kind of homeostasis that it
tries to achieve with its environment
right to get it to do something on
average that we wanted to do would would
wouldn't an alternative be to make the
agent die and have a specialized agent
with adapted Behavior rather than have
like you know complexification in a
single
agent yeah so I actually we were I had a
a rather fun convers ation with um one
of my colleagues uh a couple nights ago
at dinner um where the conversation of
what do you it was like what do you
think the AI apocalypse is going to look
like right and my response was well
actually it's not going to look like
anyone suspects because what's going to
happen is the AI agenc are just going to
start killing each other in attempt to
protect us from each other like like
like they're G to like divide into two
camps and like half the a agents are
going to like obliterate the other half
because they're trying to protect us
from them it's going to be a terrible
terrible apocalypse but the only thing
that's going to die are the artificial
agents that was my that that'll be the
first one now you know that's just one
kind of of course was a half serious
conversation yeah well no that's what um
Schmid hubba said that to us yeah um no
I I I you know I um I don't have a lot
of right and so that's another way to do
it right is that is that the agents you
know you know you want a new agent that
does something a little different right
but still achieves this nice homeostatic
equilibrium with environment so the
system is not brittle you just like kill
off the old one what yeah and the reason
I say that is um because you guys call
this approach natural intelligence as as
I understand because it's based on now
it's based on natural selection it it is
and and I guess this is a great example
of um if we were trying to you know
bootstrap this halfway up and have
agents that do multiple things I mean
that wouldn't happen in nature in nature
they would just die and a new
specialized agent would would would take
its place because you have this kind of
Niche
selection so that that sounds good to me
this has been amazing thank you so much
I really appreciate your time awesome
that was been a pleasure I always enjoy
these sorts of conversations fantastic
you have any terminal questions for me
or anything that well I mean what you
know what are you working on what's
happening over the next year also oh um
well let's see I mean many things
so uh we're at you know on the theory
side we're working on um uh you know
really formalizing this link between
systems identification Theory and Markov
blanket detection mhm um on the
pragmatic side the Markov blank the
multi-agent Markov blanket detection
algorithm you know that could do
everything from like scene segmentation
object tracking the whole nine yards um
uh building uh you know deep attentional
deep Transformer based neural networks
that do gradient free learning I'm very
excited about that um we have like the
the components are built we just got to
like start stringing them together and
then of course there's all the Robotics
and the AI project so we're we're going
to use the the same model that does the
marov blanket detection we're you know
is effectively saying that like objects
are agents right everything that has a
blanket can be considered an agent and
so there's absolutely no reason why we
can't use this and you know turn this
model around um and instead of using it
to say what is an object what is an
agent to sort of say oh well now I'm
just going to say these are agents and
they do certain things yes the
mathematics is identical the model is
the same it's just a question of are you
doing inference on observed data or are
you achieving a a specified homeostatic
equilibrium with all of these objects
and so we we you know I'm really excited
about seeing how well that works and
we'll see and and one one final question
I did mean to ask you this earlier and
and um I got way laid but um because
it's quite similar when I was playing
with Jeff Hawkins HTM algorithm um it
was it was beautiful but it was actually
lacking one thing that neuron networks
did very well which was representation
learning and um Transformers for example
and as we were saying many many
different ways of interpreting what they
do mean I like the idea that they're
basically a kind of they act as a
continuous database where the key is is
the prompt but anyway like a lot of
folks that look into um equivariant in
neuron networks they think of them as
quite plainly a way of introducing
permutation um equivariant in respect of
sets so they're they're a model for
dealing with sets and there's there's
something very Universal about that
because you know when when when we build
these predictive architectures I guess
where I'm going to with this is on on
top of doing all this beijan update and
like agent framework stuff we we
actually need to build prior in for
doing representation um encoding and I
guess that's not really something we've
spoken about so all of so we we we have
built and I really should publish this
it's it's like killing me that I have it
we've built four different kinds of
Transformers right um that are fully
basian they're fully generative right um
and they do exactly that like they do
different kinds of you could think of it
as like permutation learning right
because it's it's basically you know
like the starting point for that
analysis was kind of fun it's like well
suppose that you had like you know you
data generated from like some sort of
like you know hidden Markov model right
so you know it's like first time point
one then time point two and sort of goes
along like that um and then some bastard
came along and like shuffled the time
indices and didn't tell you what it okay
you could think of that that's what that
you know that is the looking for so
you're basically asking the question
like how do I unshuffle yeah like the
time points and you can think of that as
like that's the fundamental operation
that a Transformers for but there are
many ways to have there are many
generative models that have like those
different props you know that do that
sort of thing in various different ways
and so we've built like four of them and
that's another area of interest is we
really want to see like what are these
really good for like do these solve the
same problem you know they are subtly
different they have slightly different
properties the only the manner in which
they look like Transformers that the the
mathematics of the inferences Bas is
very very very similar but they have
different structures so so yeah that's
another like it's a really interesting
question is you know do these generative
models for Transformers have the same
performance and properties as the
standard gradient descent based learning
models of these Transformers we and we
don't know but not only that I would go
one step further so I think the agent
framework allows us here to do something
that the neuron Network folks could
never do and what what I mean by that is
um have you noticed all of these models
in your predictive architecture you you
can actually have a kind of
heterogeneous architecture and have
multiple inputs with multiple encoding
and you can bring them in and have MLPs
and but it's very monolithic it's all
left to right and now in principle you
could have multiple agents in a
multi-agent system and they will have
basically different encoders and you and
I can agree that there's probably we
need to have some kind of a library of
priors and there are a library of
primitive encoders that do primitive
things like you know things like per
permutation equivariance and like
spatial reasoning and stuff like that
have a bunch of agents that do all of
these things and all of that
complexification and and like
information sharing that will emerge
right so we don't need to explicitly
code that like we your own network yeah
you don't need some Overlord or God like
watching everyone and telling who to
talk to yeah yeah yeah yeah and and I
don't think that's been done yet so that
would be very interesting yeah no it
absolutely will be and I'm very excited
to see how that turns out to see like
you know what sort of communication you
do get between objects right how how
sophisticated does your model of the
environment in which they are embedded
have to be in order to get them to
communicate well and these are all like
incredibly interesting questions and I'm
super excited to see how it all turns
out 100% you know because they say
neural networks are biologically
inspired but I mean this I think is is
far more biologically inclined so we
need to do that anyway absolute pleasure
thank you so much for join us today it's
been amazing